[Music]
thank you and for that intro I
appreciate it as she mentioned I'm an
engineer at our studio and this is going
to be an expanded version of the talk I
gave at our studio account so I can
provide more detail on working with
api's and arm we will begin with an
overview a quick review of the Web API
basics move on to tools for accessing
those api's I have a couple of examples
prepared and a practical application
that we have built in-house using these
techniques and at the end I'll give you
some resources for finding or finding
out more information if you're
interested in expanding your knowledge
in this area so API basics there are a
lot of data accessible over the Internet
these days and a lot of it is made
available via API s which are
application programming interfaces these
allow programs to talk to each other
based on a communication contract if you
ask me a question in a way I understand
I will give you an answer so there are
two important parts to HTTP
communication over the web there's the
request which is data sent to the server
from the client and then the response
which is the data that the server sends
back to that client now this is a very
oversimplified view of the client-server
communication but the basics of it are
ask a question and get a response and
this is predicated on the fact that the
client and server need to understand
each other's language so to speak the
client can send can only send a request
to the server that the server knows how
to handle and then the server will send
that response back to the client and the
client will need to know how to parse
that response to get the data out based
on the question that was asked web api's
usually provide read and/or write access
to data stores when you're talking about
web api's and they allow you to access
data on an ongoing basis this is
significant since it allows you to write
scripts
that poll and API to get the most
up-to-date data not only away your
analyses be current but when the data
changes your scripts don't have to
depending on how you design that script
data frames and plots will update
automatically when your data changes
without you having to download a new CSV
or import data manually so as an example
of this request response I've put down
here a curl request curl as a utility in
the in the UNIX world that allows you to
make HTTP requests in this case I'm
calling the om db-api this is the online
movie database API and I'm giving it a
request with a query parameter T for
title and R for response format so in
this case I'm saying om DB give me the
data for the title the movie named clue
and send it back to me in JSON format
the server understands this request
because you've put it into the format
that it expects and so it sends a
response that contains the data you
asked for the title of the year the
rating etc again this is a very
simplistic example but it gives you an
idea of sort of how it's simple it is to
ask a question and receive an answer and
pull that data into the scripts that
you're writing everyday web api's are
organized into resources that often that
are often in a particular hierarchy in
this example there's a map that if you
follow down from the top you can get
information about accounts a particular
account by its ID the lists that a
particular account has the ID of those
lists the campaigns the subscribers the
web forms etc so these are often
organized in maps or webs of information
and if you know how to get to those
different levels of information you can
construct a URL and ask for very
specific things all the way down at the
bottom like clicks and tracked events in
this case
now that presumes that you understand a
little bit about the API that you're
trying to use fortunatelly must most of
it have many of them I should say most
of them have decent documentation this
example is from the Star Wars API so in
this case you can
across the left the kinds of information
you can learn from this documentation
there's a getting started guide here in
the first page but the things that you
need to understand are the resources
towards the bottom and so that you know
what you can get and how to get it
for example this being the Star Wars API
you can get information about people
films starships planets vehicles etc and
the beauty of this documentation this
particular documentation is very good so
it'll tell you exactly what URL to use
to get to that information
and it'll give you an example response
as well so it will tell you how to ask
the question and what format the answer
will be in so that you can then parse it
appropriately in your script the
important part here is that you need to
learn that this learn this API contract
in order to use it effectively you need
to know how to ask the question and how
the answer will be sent back to you
fortunately again these documentation
examples are often quite good because
they want you to be able to use
successfully as well so to access these
API is and pull this information into
are you have a couple of different
options in some cases people have
already written packages that will wrap
those API calls for a given service the
examples i've provided here are for AWS
s3 this is s3 buckets and the Amazon Web
Services universe our Google Analytics
will get you information about Google
Analytics based on the the ID code that
you have for your website ACS is for the
American census information etc so some
people have already wrapped these api's
into packages that are very easy to use
you do I mean if you can use them by all
means do they make your life a lot
easier you do need to be aware that the
people writing them may not have the
same goals as you do so they've written
it to solve their problem and then made
a public but if you have other questions
that you need to ask or if there's
particular endpoints that aren't covered
in that package you may need to write
that yourself or there could be no
package for the data source that you're
trying to reach in which case you'll
write it yourself with some other tools
I recommend HTT our or hitter for making
the requests
and then JSON light or excellent XML -
for parsing the response
the most common response formats of API
calls are JSON and XML and these two
packages are extremely good at parsing
that data for you once you have the data
in your sin your script you can you can
wrangle the data the way that you
normally do with data that comes in
using the various packages in the tidy
verse to get your data in an orderly
rectangle so that you can use it for
your analyses and for your plots so hit
our request functions wrap HTTP verbs
and fortunately they match them so
they're very easy to to figure out get
is the one you'll probably be using the
most commonly if you're interested in
getting information from the web into
your scripts post is to write back to a
data store of some kind patch and put R
for updating delete is fairly obvious
and head is identical to get but without
the body so in this case you just be
getting the metadata around the request
without getting the body data and this
can be useful as you're developing to
understand sort of everything around the
data itself in a much cheaper call so to
make a request you first load hitter
with the library function then called
get with the URL in this case I am using
the Star Wars API
I'm calling planets with ID 1 so what
I'm trying to do here is get information
about Planet number 1 in the Star Wars
API database and this will give you an a
response object if you print that out
you get some really useful information
the actual URL that was used after any
redirects the HTTP status the file or
content type and the size of that
response and we'll talk a little bit
more about how to use that later so you
can use various helpers and hitter to
dig into the response object for example
the status code helper will pull out
just code itself 200 is what you want to
see that means ok successful anything
else maybe a problem that you need you
would need to handle in your code
using the headers helper will get you
everything all the metadata that came
around through the header of the
response date content type connection
transfer encoding etc there's quite a
bit there and then what most people are
used interested in is the body itself
this is the content of the response and
so you would use the content function
from hitter to pull that out and here
I'm just looking at the structure of it
so you can see that it is a list into
the the various amounts of data that
come back you'll see some of it is
nested some of it is URLs so you're
going to need to understand though this
in order to handle it appropriately in
your scripts so there are three main
parts that you'll probably be most
interested in in your HTTP response the
first is status you can get these status
the full status information with the
HTTP status function it'll tell you all
of everything that it possibly can about
the status in most cases you're only
interested in the code so the status
code sorry object will come back with
just the number that you can you can
make decisions in your code based on
that number in most cases you can
automatically throw a warning or raise
an error if ever succeed if it was not
200 with the warn for status and stop
for status helpers in the hitter package
I highly recommend these they convert
HTTP errors into our errors making them
much easier to handle in your script and
they'll either warn or stop just as say
as they imply the second of the
components that you'll want to be
interested that you want to handle are
the headers themselves date content type
connection allow things like that there
can be custom headers in here it really
depends on the API that you're working
with the one that you'll probably be
using most often is the content type
most api's have a pretty consistent
content type in their response in this
case they're using JSON so you may only
have to worry about this once but if
you're calling it an familiar API or
you're calling an API that changes
frequently it may behoove you to take a
look at that content type to make sure
that what you're parsing in your script
matches what you're being sent
you can also get cookies if you're
interested really depends on your API or
your or what you're trying to get out of
it but the thing again that most people
are interested in is the body you use
the content function in hitter to get
the response body in this case you pass
it your object and a modifier so in this
case I want a character vector so I'm
going to pass in the word text and it'll
give me back all of that information
that we just saw earlier in the
structure output if you have non text
responses you can get the raw content
with the raw modifier or you can give it
the parsed this hitter has some default
parsers for common file types including
JSON XML and a couple of others this can
be really useful if if you want a quick
and dirty look at it but honestly I tend
to want to give the the the parse I want
to do the parsing explicitly and so I
don't tend to use this very often but
it's there if you want it so let's turn
now to some examples here I've got some
examples from the Star Wars universe see
if I can make that a little bigger for
you great so this I'm going to be
working with a Star Wars API in these
examples and we're just going to walk
through some of the basics of how to
deal with API is in our first thing I'm
going to do is pull in hitter JSON light
because I know that the response is
going to be in JSON and recruiter for
piping to make it easier to read the
code as I'm passing this data around and
our first goal is to get the data for
the planet Alderaan so the components of
this request in hitter are the same as
they are in HTTP you need a verb or a
message in this case get a URL endpoint
to hit in this case we're looking for
planets and a parameter here we're going
to use search not all API points
endpoints need parameters but in this
case I'm explicitly going to do a search
and in this API the key value pair is
search and then your text that you want
to search on so if I run this
you'll see that the hitter method get'
is in use it's very straightforward it's
very readable and I can take a look at
that in a second but I also wanted to
point out here that there's different
ways to do your parameters if you have
many parameters if you've got six
parameters this URL gets crazy long and
hard to read so there's another format
you can use with the get method where
you pass in a query list and you give it
your key value pairs in that list we
don't need to do that here since I've
only got one but it's worth pointing out
especially if you're if you're looking
for a very detailed data that has a lot
of parameters in the in the search query
or in the set of parameters you're
sending to the API so now that I have
that data I'm going to take a look at
the data frame names and I've got URL
status code headers cookies the content
itself in the request and things like
that so I'm getting back a lot of
information from this API which is great
I'm going to take a look specifically at
the status code this is a 200 excellent
that means it's exceeded and then I'm
going to take a look at the headers
specifically the content type in its
JSON which is what we expect again if
you're looking at an API that you don't
know very well these fields can help you
quite a bit in terms of deciding how to
to handle the data that comes back now
if I want the text of the response I'm
going to use the content method and
hitter pass at the object I just created
tell it to give me text and specify the
encoding hitter will default to utf-8
but it throws a little warning so I just
usually just go ahead and put it in
there explicitly if you take a look at
the resulting object it's giving you a
count a next a previous and the results
themselves and this is containing the
data that you're interested for the most
part it's not very easy to read and it's
not very easy to get that data back out
it's not very are formatted at the
moment so we're going to need to parse
this you can do so with hitter as I
mentioned earlier so if you passed that
into the content method with the parsed
modifier here you can
I'm gonna go ahead and run that and then
I'll take a look at it it's easier to
read then this is up here but it's
harder to get it but it's not
necessarily easy to get to some of the
information in the results themselves so
the count is pretty straightforward and
the results you know if you take a look
at the structure it's what we would
expect it all looks fine you've got some
nested elements here under residents and
films and those are actual links to
those which makes it really really easy
to get that data programmatically so
it's all there and it's all usable and
it's great but in order to access this
stuff it's a little bit ugly in terms of
this code at the end of the world I've
seen worse but it's not always that easy
to figure out kind of how that structure
works so I use JSON light to parse this
instead the JSON light package so I'm
going to take that text content that we
had up here you can see that down here
in the console you have this I'm going
to pass that to the from JSON function
in JSON light and what this is going to
do
I just ran that code and then we're
going to look at the object again gives
you the count and the next in the
previous and we'll talk about that in a
second but the results are much easier
to handle in my opinion there's
certainly much easier to handle than
this so now that you've got
parsed in JSON content I'm going to look
specifically at the results and get the
names and now it's a standard
rectangular object that we can deal with
a lot more easily and when you want to
pull that data out this code is a lot
easier to work with my easier to read in
my opinion than this code up here so I
do tend to use JSON like just to make my
life easier